Donald Trump the first president elected
without any prior experience as a human
being now this this morning Trump
actually had some major news for us that
Abu Bakr al-baghdadi the head of Isis
had been killed and in classic Trump
fashion he was able to take something
fundamentally positive and express it in
the weirdest imaginable way because here
is how he described the operation they
did a lot of shooting and they did a lot
of blasting even not going through the
front door you know you think you go
through the door if you're a normal
person you say knock knock
may I come in the fact is that they
blasted their way into the house they
had a beautiful big hall and they ran in
and they got everybody by surprised what
are you doing only just learn how
soldiers work listen these guys are
amazing they got these chameleon suits
and big shooties and blast ease they
don't say knock knock no they don't do
that like a normal person
they go through big beautiful holes and
they shout surprise a lot of people are
learning about this for the first time
this is new to a lot of people but wait
because you haven't yet heard Trump pay
tribute to one crucial member of the
team or a canine as they call I call it
a dog a beautiful girl a talented boy I
call them dogs not like other people who
call them furry lizards or barking cats
or elephants but smaller and different
to me they are and forever will be dogs
that's my term for them that I made up
and what I look what Baghdady being gone
is clearly great news I'd actually like
to focus tonight on a different decision
Trump recently made in the same region
and one that I would argue could have
more long-term ramifications and which
tells us much more about his
decision-making as commander in chief
it's a move that alarmed many even his
cheerleaders on Fox and Friends the
United States is going to start pulling
troops from Turkey's border in Syria
that announcement last night stunning
the White House says it's clearing the
way for Turkish troops to invade a
disaster a series of events I hope the
president will rethink this Wow
you know things are bad for Trump when
he's even lost the support of Fox &
Friends a show whose actual slogan is
president Trump's dick is 17 inches long
and thick as a true tire that's the real
slogan now very basically what happened
here was Trump suddenly and against the
Council of nearly all his advisers
pulled back troops along the
syria-turkey border here who had been
working with Kurdish LED forces to
contain Isis and it wasn't just that our
presence there also helped protect
Kurdish civilians from Turkey Isis and
the Syrian government and our troop
withdrawal has had immediate
consequences Turkish forces moved in
almost as soon as we left and over a
hundred civilians have been killed with
nearly 200,000 displaced it has been a
catastrophe and this move has been
nearly universally condemned it's been
criticized by everyone from Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren to Mitch
McConnell and Lindsey Graham the last of
whom did not mince his words to abandon
these people is a real show and I'm
hoping President Trump will reconsider
he's about to make the biggest mistake
of his presidency hope he adjust a
show although to be fair Lindsey Graham
always looks like he's just said that
exact phrase you know I come into this
Bojangles every Sunday the read Sunday
and I have never seen service like this
magic in his damp my biscuit is cold my
day is ruined people this is a real
show right here I will take my order to
go
and when when the consequences of a
decision of that dire and the
condemnation that widespread it feels
like it might be worth asking what
exactly happened
why did Trump decide to do it and what
might the ramifications be going forward
and let's start with what happens now
obviously the situation in Syria is
incredibly complex you can be forgiven
for not fully understanding it what is
much less forgivable it's pretending to
understand it when you clearly don't say
very semi complicated not too
complicated if you're smart but it's a
semi complicated problem oh good it's
only semi complicated is it I'd
forgotten that Trump spent the 90s is
the senior fellow for Middle Eastern
Studies at the Foreign Policy Research
Institute and not as I clearly wrongly
remembered losing all his dad's money
and trying unsuccessfully to bang
Madonna
I forgot that because clearly are not
smart like him look there are more
factions involved here than we have time
to cover but the important group to know
about are the Kurds there are about
thirty million of them in the region
spread mostly across Syria Turkey Iraq
and Iran they are the largest ethnic
group in the world without a country of
their own so they're their own minority
wherever they live putting them in a
precarious situation but it's important
to know that they have been close
military allies with America in the past
which is why it was so odd to hear Trump
justify abandoning them like this
somebody wrote in a very very powerful
article today they didn't help us in the
Second World War they didn't help us
with no Normandy as an example they
mentioned names of different battles
they were there but they're there to
help us with their land and that's a
different thing hold on let me let me
let me just get this straight you aren't
mad because the Kurds didn't help the
u.s. fight in Normandy quick question
the does that have to do with
anything there were also no Kurt at the
Battle of Gettysburg or helping us get
to the moon Oh suspiciously Kurdish
missions where were the cards Neil could
have used their help holding his ladder
that were all busy were they all of them
the fact is the Kurds have fought
multiple times to help America including
in both the Gulf and Iraq Wars meaning
by the way the Kurds fought with the US
military in at least two more wars than
Donald Trump ever do we turn to
the curse in 2015 to help us contain
Isis in Syria we provided training and
air support and they were the frontline
troops doing the close fighting and it
was a very tight partnership the US
military trusted their allies so
completely that the Kurds were soon
calling in American airstrikes it's true
the Kurds would point at something and
we would blow it up that's an incredible
level of trust if I had that power to
put it mildly there would be no more
Applebee's they know what they did they
know what they did now that the Kurds
sacrifice in that fight was significant
while at least six Americans died
fighting in that region the Kurds
suffered 11,000 casualties and that
Alliance is one of the reasons why Isis
which controlled this much territory in
Syria in 2015 has since lost all of it
in fact a key reason that we were able
to take out al Baghdadi was thanks to
intelligence from the Kurds so they
fought bravely with us and the situation
in northeastern Syria was relatively
stable and then in an instant Trump
threw that all away so why why did he do
that well to hear him tell it it's
actually pretty simple I don't want to
be in Syria forever it's sand and it's
death okay first since when does Trump
avoid areas of sand and death
he owns a golf club in Florida where the
average age is opposed the Civil Rights
Act the guy loves sand and death but
that is part of his reductive argument
that in America should not be stuck in
endless wars and that the troops should
come home which is at least a real
coherent foreign policy position the
problem is the troops aren't actually
coming home since May we've actually
increased the number of them deployed to
the Middle East by 14,000 and just days
after his Syria decision
Trump made a big announcement we are
sending troops and other things to the
Middle East to help Saudi Arabia but are
you ready
Saudi Arabia at my request has agreed to
pay us for everything we're doing that's
the first okay so one it's probably one
surprise you they have not agreed to
that and so even if they had that would
be a weird thing to brag about the US
military doesn't charge for protection
because it isn't a mercenary force
it's the reason the eagle on the US seal
carries arrows and an olive branch not
arrows and a credit card reader but but
the idea that we'll send troops to a
country that pays us is definitely in
keeping with Trump's short-term purely
transactional worldview it's the same
philosophy that's led him to suggest
withdrawing troops from South Korea
because he thinks they're not paying us
enough or to threatened to pull out NATO
because he thinks other countries aren't
contributing their fair share so look
I'm sorry kurds unless you can give
Donald Trump something he wants like I
don't know hunter Biden's email password
or Melania Trump's phone number you can
apparently expect fuck-all from him so
if this wasn't done out of some grand
principle why did it happen and happened
so suddenly
well it seems Trump's decision followed
a phone call with President Erdogan of
Turkey and a little context here for
years Turkey has struggled with a
Kurdish militant group called the PKK
who are unquestionably extreme the State
Department considers them a terrorist
group and Iran firmly believes that a
Kurdish group we've been working with
are basically the same as the PKK and he
wants them either dead or nowhere near
the Turkish border but this isn't
actually a new problem we've been
basically managing to balance our
interest in containing Isis with our
needs to manage our ones concerns for
years now it has been difficult but
we've basically done it until it seems
her Dewan got on the phone with Trump
earlier this month and told him he
wanted to move against Kurdish forces in
Syria and Trump essentially said fine
we'll run away then and that is a
decision that has baffled many including
MIT Romney air Dewan basically said
we're coming in get out of the way and
America blinked is am i reading that
wrong
no MIT you're actually not much like the
rest of America discovering this week
that your secret Twitter account was
named Pierre de lecto that's real you
are very much not reading that wrong
incidentally Pierre de lecto sounds like
a name that would have come up in pulp
fiction if that conversation about
French McDonald's had kept going in
France they called the quarter-pounder a
Royale with cheese and they call grimace
piel de Lecter but it is truly troubling
the sheer extent to which Trump has just
rolled over for Dewan he called the
Kurds who remember have repeatedly
fought and died alongside the US
military no angels and while at one
point Trump did apparently try to
prevent a Kurdish slaughter other one
seems to feel pretty comfortable
ignoring him yesterday a letter surface
from President Trump to erdowan he
warned against a Turkish military
offensive and said in decidedly
undiplomatic language don't be a tough
guy don't be a fool Derwin reportedly
threw away the letter and launched the
assault into Syria the same day holy
he didn't just ignore him other one
threw away a piece of mail that day
that alone is ice-cold he probably also
throws away birthday cards directly
after reading them like a monster
instead of keeping them on the kitchen
counter for a week out of a sense of
irrational guilt and then throwing them
out because what else are you going to
do
frame it of course not it's a piece of
trash but not for a week but even even
if you think Trump was right to withdraw
troops from the area it clearly makes
sense to do it in a way that will cause
the least damage to the region your
alloys and your own interests but Trump
did none of that a withdrawal was so
rushed we had to leave a lot behind just
watch this Russian reporter wandering
around a US base just hours after the
troops had left but even through
ordinary left here yesterday at 4 a.m.
look here I am currently at the u.s.
kitchen American soldiers used to eat
here the fridge is full
good cooler what so not only did we dump
our alloys without warning we left a
refrigerator full of free coke for
whoever took our place although maybe
the most interesting part of that video
is watching the reporter blatantly
ignore the fridge full of Pepsi right
next to it because even two Russian
reporters the answer to is Pepsi okay is
a resounding yet so so basically America
left the region the same way you leave a
party right after you clog to the toilet
quickly leaving everything behind and
forcing someone else to deal with all
the and the consequences to this
have been dire for starters Kurdish led
forces were in charge of guarding many
Isis prisoners and by leaving so
abruptly we forced them to abandon their
posts to fight for their lives and the
thing that any six-year-old could tell
you what happened next happened next the
White House has tried to downplay how
many of the 10,000 Isis prisoners in
Syria may have escaped there were a few
that got out a small number relatively
speaking and they've been largely
recaptured but that's not what the
president's special envoy for Syria
James Jeffery said on Wednesday we would
say that the number is now over a
hundred we do not know where they are
it's true
over a hundred Isis prisoners escaped
and we don't know where they are or at
least they don't know where they are
because I have a surprise for everyone
here tonight ladies and gentlemen the
Isis prisoners
[Applause]
[Music]
why didn't we give them shovels just
doesn't make any sense anyway as I was
saying over a hundred Isis prisoners
have escaped and we have no idea where
they are and the thing is it gets even
worse here because when you give a green
light to an authoritarian terrible
things can happen and terrible things
very much did we saw for the first time
alleged atrocities carried out by
Turkish backed Arab militias this video
today appears to show Arab militias
executing occured by the roadside as
they shout Allah Akbar and proudly
saying film me film me that is
horrifying a potential war crime and
completely completely avoidable yet
astonishingly even in the face of scenes
like that and over a hundred civilian
deaths remember Trump was actually tried
to spin the carnage as evidence of his
tactical genius
it was unconventional what I did I said
they're gonna have to fight a little
while sometimes you have to let them
fight a little while then people find
out how tough the fighting is sometimes
you have to let them fight it's like you
kids it a lot you gotta let him fight
and then you pull them apart so are
you talking about that is not true for
Syria and it's also not true for kids
you weird monster some just revealed
what we've essentially always known
he's not just a shitty president and a
shitty person he's a shitty dad thank
God he never had to raise any children
now
so faithfully faithfully the worst of
the violence appears to have abated at
least for the moment but that is largely
because after the u.s. left a power
vacuum in the region another major
player stepped in Russia's Vladimir
Putin tonight became the new kingmaker
in Syria as he and Turkey's president
air21 carved up the country between them
exactly Putin now has a larger foothold
in the region and the Kurdish fighters
who were once allied with us for so long
have now flipped sides and struck a deal
with Syria's Bashar al-assad to avoid
being wiped out so Trump has made a snap
decision where the big winners are Putin
uh dawuan Assad and Isis and that is a
group that you do not want to be
friendly with although actually believe
they will all know the Cowboys game with
Ellen this weekend look look we're all
different and that's okay but but Trump
but Trump may not be bothered
particularly that he's empowered so many
authoritarianism or for them in fact
even after earned Awan disregarded
Trump's warnings and launched a bloody
campaign once he'd agreed to a temporary
ceasefire Trump went straight back to
effusive ly praising him I just want to
thank and congratulate though President
Erdogan he's a friend of mine and I'm
glad we didn't have a problem because
frankly he's a hell of a leader and he's
a tough man he's a strong man and he did
the right thing yeah he's a strong man
he's a strong man that's not a
compliment that's a synonym for dictator
and that image might actually sum up the
insanity of this whole situation the
president thinking he's projecting
strength obsequious ly fawning over an
authoritarian thought deigning to pause
a slaughter that the President himself
had enabled and look I know that it is
it is so easy to criticize anyone's
policy in this region it is very
complicated any move is going to have
ripple effects intended or otherwise
Syria was one of the biggest problem
spots in Obama's foreign policy so I'm
not saying that it is easy or even
possible to get a situation this
difficult completely right but
it's genuinely hard to get it this wrong
we took a fundamentally stable situation
betrayed a strategically vital alloy and
immensely damaged our reputation just
watch how the Kurds treated a u.s.
convoy leaving the country Kurdish
civilians until now close US allies
throwing potatoes and yelling insults at
American troops ordered out of Syria
these images tonight show one of the
lowest moments of America's reputation
in the Middle East in years think about
what he just said there one of the
lowest moments of America's reputation
in the Middle East and remember a guy in
the Middle East
once took off his shoe threw it at the
president and then while the people
around him watched took off his other
shoe and also threw that at the
president look the more you look at all
of this the more worried it gets because
this was an unforced error Trump chose
to do something this sudden this
impetuous and this damaging and he's
just not going to change to imagine what
he might do in a crisis not of his own
making that is one of the many
terrifying things about the prospect of
a second term or indeed the remaining
year of this first one because there is
nothing more dangerous than someone with
a massive amount of power a dictator
fetish and an inability to think in
anything but transactional terms and who
is stupid enough to think that this is
all not too complicated if you are smart
you